let's try that when I do the strike I
want all my organization on that okay so
like everything is hitting there when I
do this point now to do that what block
would be force on force that's a clash
okay so I need to go in this case what I
did was going under it so that means
that my Center has to draw my Center has
to draw my Center does not keep turning
in you see so I was going in felt it and
underneath it so if you just look here
you keep looking at my hand you want to
look here today so I here's the strike
and no one can do it okay so that's not
what's happening in fact what is
happening is what I mentioned the other
day where you you have to have both the
capacity for concentration and a
capacity for detachment so which means
unattach me detach me okay so I'm doing
my chemo was that right and I have all
my concentration on the strike ooh
but the second I tell that it's not
going to be what I wanted it to be then
immediately I have detached from that
commitment okay and to you the observer
you don't know which is why some of you
stopped throwing the strikes and just
went right to a projection you see and
what was happening then it's not setting
up is nice
have the relationship is nice all those
things are happy but it's not that you
know I go do one thing or I do many
things at once he said I do one thing as
fully as I can and I immediately let go
and it's not working for me
there in the in the traditional record
you have variations on that explanation
so you know what the good good with it
you know following you and young right
you're gonna have full commitment but
what tiny bit a little bit Mitchell
you'll see you give it off so I feel I
think that's now you're trying to make
the metaphor we'll just understand it's
about full concentration and then as
needed a full detachment full unattach
[Music]
I think yeah as a beginner technique I
don't think that is the way that you
actually cultivate this skill I do think
that that is the way that you begin to
problematize the fact that I can't do it
at all because most of us are totally
unaware that we stop the hand right or
that we're on the bottom and not on the
top so by slowing it down so that your
your intellect can take note of and
observe right yet that's like the first
step towards a different you but as far
as the skill goes that skill
traditionally and I am in accordance
with this that is what we moderns would
call that's an original religious
relight realization that's a spiritual
maturity that has to happen and so you
need to cultivate it through those means
that's going to be service that's going
to be fasting and that's going to be
zazen right all the things where are our
pride our fear all the things that get
in the way of detachment fear pride
ignorance all of that that has that's
how you do it so you take your practice
and you make it an attempt to purify out
or to reconcile fear pride ignorance
then this mind will follow and you
cannot do that just by observing
yourself in the technique you can kind
of lead that in like we say you can use
the teacher as a means of generating a
reconciliation with fear pride and
ignorance because the teacher is a tool
a technology in which you self displace
you see your ego your fear your pride
wants you to do the technique this way
but by your commitment to the mentor to
the master to the abbot you are
practicing self displacement in doing
the technique exactly
let's describe so then in that case
kielbasa can do it and you guys
came here and then you had this throwing
effort okay why don't I have a timing
that when I hit in that spot his elbow
hits that do you understand do you guys
see that difference so I am NOT going
like this and whoa I am moving in such a
way that later when I hit this hand
positioning his Center is already
connected to that point and so he
projects off of that you get that so
that that concept right is that's the
art that's why this fate because
everyone goes you did with your arm
didn't have you need just throwing
himself and why everyone who does
because I don't know how he threw me I
don't know because next thing I know I
was in there but it's just physics
he's landing on the greater resistance
of the earth of my base so he's good at
projec
okay so yeah just let it be that's the
trick that's the trick so go to your
Taoist philosophy wu wei wu wei is the
concept also translated as you know
non-action obviously i'm acting it's
really just you know no preference based
agency or the way that i like to
translate doing the right thing doing
only the thing that needs to be done no
more no less
okay that's cool